i just want to find
uh 11 780
votes well it took some time but it
looks like we finally found
some voter fraud we're only a couple of
days into 2021 and there is
already a new trump tape i have to find
12 000 votes and i have them times
a lot and therefore i won the state
it's been just about a year since
president trump made the perfect phone
call
to ukraine where he attempted to
leverage over 400 million dollars in
american taxpayer aid to ukraine that
call was perfect
it couldn't have been nicer in an
attempt to get help against his main
political rival joe biden
but it appears that president trump is
not done with the 2020 election
now the washington post has obtained
bombshell audio of a
over one hour-long phone call between on
the one hand president trump mark
meadows and a lawyer for the president
clena mitchell of the firm foley and
lardner
and on the other hand georgia secretary
of state brad raffensberger and
secretary of state general counsel
ryan germany and the parties for over an
hour discussed the georgia election and
during this call president trump
shall we say expresses his extreme
concern about the numbers
in georgia that the certified election
results
have gone for joe biden the
president-elect
and on the other hand georgia secretary
of state brad raffensberger says that
the numbers are correct that there was
no impropriety and that they are very
confident in those numbers and that
the information the president has is at
best incorrect
but our question for today is whether
the newest leaked audio has put
president trump in criminal jeopardy or
not
now i'm not going to go into whether you
can indict a sitting president because
we've talked about that a million times
on this channel and also president trump
is not going to be the sitting president
for very long also let's not get bogged
down in whether he can pardon himself
moving on and not surprisingly already a
number of right-wing outlets are saying
that the
crime is not the phone call itself but
the fact that someone would dare to leak
a non-private phone call with the
president of
the united states though i think those
arguments not only are they made in bad
faith but
here they don't hold water because on
the morning that the tape was released
president trump tweeted out
i spoke to secretary of state brad
raffensburger yesterday about fulton
county and voter fraud in georgia he was
unwilling or unable to answer
questions such as the ballots under the
table scam ballot destruction
out-of-state voters dead voters and more
he has no clue
to which raffensburger responded there
was no agreement and we didn't know what
the purpose of the call really was we
assumed it was about the november
election and really wednesday if
president trump wouldn't have tweeted
out anything and would have stayed
silent
we would have stayed silent as well and
some people are claiming that this is a
confidential settlement conference
regarding litigation and while there is
such a thing as
confidential settlement agreements i've
participated in many of them
the thing is if you disclose the content
of
that conference then arguably you have
waived your privilege
to that content so it's likely that even
if privilege attached which
i don't think would be the case uh in
this particular phone call
arguably the president has waived any
claim to privilege here
so what's the big deal about this phone
call
the people of the country are angry and
there's nothing wrong with saying that
you know uh that you've recalculated
well actually there could be a lot wrong
with saying that you recalculated
if you haven't actually recalculated if
you're not allowed to recalculate if you
recalculate for pretextual reasons
or if you use the recalculation to
change the numbers inappropriately
there's a lot that can be at issue here
so let's start with
georgia state law the first part of
georgia code section 21-2-562 deals with
fraudulent entries unlawful alteration
or destruction of entries unlawful
removal of documents
and neglect or refusal to deliver
documents it's obviously against
georgia law to falsify documents or
records in connection with an election
or
to make any false entries and then
there's georgia code section 21-2-576
destroying or defacing or delaying
delivery of ballots any person who
willfully destroys or defaces any ballot
or willfully delays the delivery of any
ballots
shall be guilty of a misdemeanor then
there's section 45-11-1
offenses involving public records
documents or other items
it's against georgia law for public
officials to falsify any record
related to their office and then there's
section 21-2-597 intentional
interference with performance of
election duties
under georgia law any person who
intentionally interferes with hinders or
delays or attempts to interfere with
hinder or delay any other person in the
performance of any act or duty
authorized or imposed by this chapter
shall be guilty of a misdemeanor and
that refers to the election duties of
election
related officials in georgia and then
there's section 21-2-604 good
old-fashioned criminal solicitation
to commit election fraud and the
important thing to note in terms of this
solicitation offense which is actually
the case
with most solicitation crimes is that
it's not a defense that the person you
solicited
did not take the bait and those are just
the obvious georgia state-related
election crimes then there's a whole
swath
of federal law related to elections the
department of justice guidance on
federal prosecutions for voter fraud
states that the following are
prosecutable election crimes
malfeasance by election officials acting
under color of law such as diluting
valid ballots with invalid ones
so-called ballot box stuffing
rendering false vote tabulations or
preventing valid voter registrations or
votes from being given effect in any
election as well as in elections where
federal candidates
are on the ballot now 18 usc sections
241 and 242
are the civil rights conspiracy statutes
section 241 states
if two or more persons conspire to
injure a press threaten or intimidate
any person in any state
in the free exercise or enjoyment of any
right or privilege secured to him by the
constitution or laws of the united
states
or because of his having so exercised
the same they shall be fined under this
title or imprison not more than 10 years
or both
and the next section 242 makes it a
crime for any person acting under color
of law statute ordinance regulation or
custom
to willfully deprive her cause to be
deprived from any person those rights
privileges or immunities secured
or protected by the constitution in the
laws united states that includes
depriving people of their right to vote
and have their vote properly counted and
then the other most likely applicable
federal law would be the national voter
registration act
now codified as 52 usc 2501
which also makes it legal for election
officials to commit fraud
specifically anyone who knowingly and
willfully deprives defrauds or attempts
to deprive or defraud the residents of a
state of a fair and impartially
conducted election process by
the procurement casting or tabulation of
ballots that are known by the person to
be materially false
fictitious or fraudulent under the laws
of the state in which
the election is held so those are the
state and federal laws that are most
likely to apply in this particular
situation
so the question is do they actually
apply did the president actually violate
one of these criminal election related
statutes
well as we've discussed many times on
this channel often criminality requires
a specific mental state
a mens rea and this case is no different
sometimes
the same actual physical conduct can be
criminal depending on the particular
mental state that someone had and the
criminal justice system
is actually very very concerned with
the intent that someone has and here
most of the state and federal election
crimes require
mental states of either willfulness or
intentionality
and those carry very specific meanings
in the world of criminal law
willfulness is generally defined as
meaning the prosecutor must prove beyond
a reasonable doubt
that the defendant knew that their
conduct was unlawful
and intended to do something that the
law forbids that is that they acted with
a purpose to disobey or disregard the
law
now many states define willfulness and
intentionality
slightly differently it's a very
ambiguous term within the the world of
criminal law that's actually why
people have tried to adopt what's called
a model penal code but we'll save that
for another day
now i looked and i couldn't find how
georgia defines or construes its
willfulness requirement
in the context of these election law
violations but you will notice that the
federal laws also
use the willfulness requirement and
there is some case law with respect to
the federal laws here uh for
president trump to be convicted under
section 242 for example
a prosecutor would have to show three
elements that he acted under color of
law
that he acted willfully and that he
deprived or attempted to deprive someone
of the rights of the constitution or
federal
law and courts have interpreted section
242 to impose a
specific intent requirement the
prosecutor would need to show that the
president acted with a specific intent
to deprive someone of a constitutional
right or
with an open defiance or in reckless
disregard of a constitutional
requirement
and as always the criminal justice
system looks to the context and
circumstantial evidence to determine
someone's mental state because no one
can
read minds and recall that
circumstantial evidence isn't weak it's
often
the strongest evidence that we have so
let's look to the call itself and see
what a prosecutor and
defense attorney would argue in the
context of this call
and the general election now arguably
president trump's greatest exposure is
probably
under these solicitation laws president
trump seemingly
asked brad raffensberger not to count
legal votes
he asked him to find the exact number of
votes needed to overturn the result
just one more than joe biden got would
do it in
one portion of the call president trump
seemingly accuses
both brad raffensberger and the general
counsel for the secretary of state ryan
germany
of engaging in criminal conduct and
you're going to find that they are
which is totally illegal it's it's it's
more illegal for you than it is for them
because you know what they did and
you're not reporting it that's a you
know that's a
criminal that's a criminal offense and
and you know you can't let that happen
that's
that's a big risk to you and to ryan
your lawyer that's a big risk a threat
that comes from the president of the
united states who of course controls the
department of justice
he says that it's criminal and you can't
let that happen
it's a risk it's a big risk to both
raffensberger and
germany when the president of the united
states says that you're engaging in
criminal conduct that carries a
different kind of weight
than when you're just joe shmoe on the
street
and then right after that particular
section where he's saying that
the georgia officials have engaged in
criminal conduct
he then goes on to say that uh he just
wants
11 780 votes
you know i mean i'm notifying you that
you're letting it happen
so look all i want to do is this i just
want to find
uh 11 780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state and that number
could be incredibly important
because he's not saying he wants all of
the fraudulently cast ballots or that he
wants
all of the uh incorrectly cast ballots
to be
reversed in his favor he wants
specifically
one more vote than joe biden won the
state by
uh president trump in many different
spots says that
joe biden ostensibly has won georgia by
11 779.
thus president trump wants just one more
than that
and that could go a long way towards
establishing the mens rea
of the criminality that he knows that
the numbers are false
and that he just wants one single vote
more he doesn't care exactly how many
gets as long as he beats joe biden
and then arguably in almost the next
sentence
he says that he doesn't exactly care how
georgia does it
call it a mistake call it a
recalculation just do it and flip the
state
and flipping the state is a great
testament to our country because
you know and there's this there's just
it's a testament that they can admit to
a mistake or whatever you want to call
it if it was a mistake i don't know
a lot of people think it wasn't a
mistake it was much more
uh criminal than that and then president
trump seemingly goes on to
cajole the georgia officials in speak
that
literally sounds like a mobster so what
are we going to do here folks i only
need 11 000 votes
fellas i need 11 000 votes give me a
break
uh you know we have that in spades
already
what are we gonna do fellas give me a
break we have in spades already
i mean he really does seem like he
watched a bunch of 1940s gangster movies
and president trump just can't even
fathom why a republican official in
georgia
wouldn't be trying to do everything
possible to give the
election to a republican president why
don't you want to find this right what's
wrong with you i heard that i heard
your lawyer is very difficult actually
but i'm sure you're a good lawyer
you have a nice last name but but i'm
just curious
why wouldn't why why do you keep
fighting
this thing it just doesn't make sense
and then president trump goes on to say
that
they need to re-examine the election
results but they need to re-examine it
with people that want to find the
answers
seemingly implying that they should use
people who are in on the fix and
will actually flip the results
so tell me brad what are we going to do
we won the election and it's not fair to
take it away from us like this
and it's going to be very costly in many
ways
and i think you have to say that you're
going to re-examine it and
you can re-examine it but but re-examine
it with people that
want to find answers not people that
don't want to find answers
so assuming that the actual acts here
rise to the level of the the various
election crimes that we discussed and
frankly getting a secretary of state to
literally change the votes to turn an
outcome probably
qualifies for a lot of the things that
we previously talked about
a prosecutor would argue that these
statements show that president trump
does have the requisite mental state for
these crimes
there is a specific intent to violate
the law and engage in criminality a
prosecutor would say
president trump is going after exactly
the number of votes that's needed to
flip the state
that he's recognizing that the
information is against him and that he
doesn't seriously believe that uh that
he actually won the state
that he is uh threatening the officials
in charge of the election results in
georgia
not only that but later on in the tapes
he talks about uh
how all the good things will happen to
uh raffensberger and germany if they do
flip the state
in his favor so he's offering both
carrots and sticks to change the results
and it appears that he's single-mindedly
focused on the outcome rather than the
process
on the other hand a defense attorney for
president trump would argue based on the
context of the call
and on the explicit language of the call
itself
that president trump did not engage in
criminality that the
statements that we just talked about
make sense in context
and certainly everyone would agree that
president trump never explicitly said
invent fake votes so that he wins the
election
it appears that throughout the call
president trump has an honest belief
a subjective honest belief that may or
may not comport with objective reality
but nonetheless an honest belief that
there was fraud in georgia
the bottom line is many many times the
11
779 margin that they said we lost by
uh we had vast i mean you have
the state is in turmoil uh over this
and i know you would like to get to the
bottom of it he seems fixated by it he
seems
to believe everything that uh the
uh social media orders he calls it the
trump media he
says he does not watch social media he
watches
uh trump media but he appears to
believe everything that those sources
are
saying and also that dominion took out
machines
uh that dominion is really moving fast
to get rid of their
uh machinery do you know anything about
that
because that's illegal ryan germany no
dominion has not
um moved any machinery out of fulton
county we're having oh but no but
but if they move have they have they
moved
the inner parts of the machines and
replaced them with other parts
no you sure ryan
i'm sure i'm sure mr president it's it's
total nonsense but he seems to actually
believe it
so in the context of that
of the the trump news media and
president trump is looking into
ways of addressing the fraud that he
honestly believes took place
and yes president trump referred to the
number 11780 which is a very convenient
number for the president that's a number
that would flip georgia
but really throughout the call president
trump is referring to lots of different
numbers
related to the claimed election fraud at
some times talking about 300 000
mysterious ballots or uh quote
massive numbers far greater than the 11
779
or he says that accurate numbers would
include
more than 50s of thousands he's
convinced that there are
far more than the number of votes
necessary for him to win
and he's just concerned about finding
enough at one point he says he doesn't
want to go after dominion
because he doesn't need to because there
are all these other
votes that were fraudulently cast that
total far
more than twelve thousand so therefore
they don't even need to get into the
dominion thing
and at the same time the president's
lawyer cletu mitchell of foley and
lardner says that
what they're trying to get is the data
from georgia that
georgia for legal and uh privacy reasons
has not disclosed
a lot of the election related data to
them so they actually can't
check some of these fraud related claims
and they simply want the data to be able
to make that check
though that may seemingly be illegal in
and of itself
i think what president's saying what
we've been trying to do is to say look
the court is not acting on our petition
they haven't even assigned a judge
but the people of georgia and the people
of america have a right to know
the answers and you have data and
records that we don't have access to
and then unfortunately there's the
additional problem that a lot of
the president's thoughts are completely
encoded the problem is the president has
brain worms brain worms at one point in
the call
he says that he literally thinks that he
won every state in the country
oh every single state we want every
state we want every state house in the
country
so when someone's head is filled with
complete nonsense
that actually has a big effect in terms
of trying to prove a
subjective specific intent crime so a
prosecutor would say that you have to
read between the lines you have to read
the subtext
to the text and that just like no
mafiadon would ever say
explicitly commit the crime itself it's
meant through implication and that you
have to look at the leverage
and the pressure that someone is putting
on another person to commit a crime well
a defense attorney would say this is
just someone that is
extremely concerned about the election
who has honest
if crazy beliefs about that election and
that they're just trying to explore the
legal avenues to
come to the outcome that they believe
is the right one and then finally there
is the question of apart from the
potential criminality itself
could this behavior be impeachable just
the implication
of the context itself and the answer to
that is
almost certainly yes congress has wide
discretion
to impeach and the senate to remove
uh based on impropriety and it's hard to
believe that
even if the phone call itself uh
was not criminal that based on
the the context and the implications uh
that the president
either knew or should have known that
what he was doing was improper
uh in the context of a democratic
republic and
thus its removable conduct but it
appears that president trump
finally got his wish he finally found
the election fraud
that he was looking for and when susan
collins said that she thought that
president trump had learned his lesson
from the last perfect phone call and the
last impeachment
it appears that he did learn a lesson
that
he should just do it again but on the
other hand it appears that the
democratic member of the georgia state
election board
has formally asked the georgia secretary
of state to open an investigation into
possible criminal violations
by president trump based on the phone
call so it's anyone's guess as to what's
going to happen to president trump as a
result of this phone call
both while he's in office and eventually
when he leaves